would you say women who can't find a
mate that they're attracted to are a
kind of insult
right so i get asked this all the time
it's funny when ever you pick a topic to
research like in cells one of the first
questions is what about the femme cells
well for my study i could only find nine
femme cells i would like to maybe do um
a femcel study one day and my thinking
on this has evolved somewhat initially i
would kind of agree with the incel line
that they would say there's no real such
thing as no such thing as a real fem
cell in the same way as an incel because
most women can go out and get sex or a
relationship if they want it might not
be the sex or love or relationship that
they want but they can get something and
for in cells i think this is a real
failure of cross-sex mind reading
because for in cells they kind of look
at it in a very black and white
way and perhaps a lot of men generally
do this too that they think something is
better than nothing
for men sex is like pizza there's good
pizza and there's pizza there's no bad
pizza really but for women that's not
the case and i think we're
underestimating just how much women
don't like having sex with men they
don't like having sex with it's like
repellent to them they have high
discussed sensitivity uh or low
they're like um
it's really repugnant that idea to have
to have sex with someone you don't want
and it's actually cost inflicting so
something is not better than uh than
nothing always for a woman and that's
kind of a failure of cross-sex
mind-reading i think on the behalf of
himself louise perry in her book she
talks about this
prostitute that was working on it i
think it's a prostitute rather than an
escort i don't know what the difference
is escort's just like nicer um but
and she said that one of the first
skills that you need to develop as a
prostitute is to not throw up when
you're having sex with a client because
um you you are having to give yourself
an out of body experience to detach the
emotions from what's going on to you
physically yeah that actually i listened
to that and uh
that gave me an idea for a study because
there's another evolutionary
psychologist called hannah bradshaw and
at a recent conference she presented
something undiscussed that showed that
when you have control over your
environment then your your disgust is
quite high sensitive whereas if you
don't have control over your environment
you down regulate your disgust so take
for example the pig farmer we're a
family of pig farmers in my house and if
you're working on a pig farm you don't
really have much choice to leave so you
kind of get used to the smell whereas if
you visit a pig farm for the first time
you might be like oh god get me out of
here and the fact that you can get out
would maybe make you think okay i gotta
leave this disgust is high so i think as
an idea for a study might be
to examine whether sex workers who have
more control over the clientele that
they see do they have a higher level of
sensitivity of disgust because they can
control it so they don't have to um
whereas those who are really like you
know a prostitute or a sex worker who
maybe doesn't have really that much
control they'd probably down regulate
their disgust mechanism kind of like
louise um talks about there
dude that's fascinating the pig farmer
theory of female sexual disgust my
father would be absolutely delighted if
i it will be farming into my theory
[Laughter]
i knew that all of those those hours on
the pig farm was going to work out when
it when it came to your phd what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
you